>> Laura: CONTINUING COVERAGE
OF THE IG REPORT OUT TODAY.
DESPITE A NUMBER OF EXPLOSIVE
REVELATIONS, SOME LAWMAKERS ARE
STILL SUGGESTING THE PARTS MAY
BEEN REDACTED.
JOINING ME NOT TO GIVE US
EXCLUSIVE REACTION'S HOUSE INTEL
CHAIR DEVIN NUNES.
CONGRESSMAN, THIS IS WHAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN WAITING FOR.
ON THIS MATTER, THE HILLARY
EMAIL MATTER, YOUR INITIAL
REACTION.
>> THE FIRST THING I CAN THINK
OF IS THERE WAS INFORMATION WE
GOT TODAY AT 11:00, 12:00 THAT
CHAIRMAN GOWDY HAD TO CALL AND
TELL ME WHAT IT WAS, TEXT
MESSAGES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR SINCE LATE LAST YEAR.
THESE ARE TEXT MESSAGES THAT
CLEARLY WERE PERTINENT TO OUR
INVESTIGATION AND TO FISA ABUSE
AND THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION,
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS
COLLUSION.
THESE ARE EMAILS OR TEXT
MESSAGES THAT SOMEBODY HELD A
FROM US.
EVERY DAY THAT GOES BY, THERE'S
A NEW EXAMPLE OF OBSTRUCTION OF
THE CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: I WANT TO READ TO
YOU BETWEEN AN EXCHANGE BETWEEN
LISA PAGE AND PETER STRZOK, THE
STAR-CROSSED LOVERS.
SHE BASICALLY SAID SHE WAS --
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO GET
ELECTED, RIGHT, RIGHT?
HE ANSWERS BASICALLY DON'T
WORRY.
WE WILL STOP IT.
NO, NO, NO, WE WILL STOP IT.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
THE LEAD INVESTIGATOR, THE LEAD
INVESTIGATOR.
>> LEAD INVESTIGATOR ON THE
CLINTON EMAIL CASE.
STARTS OFF THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION USING OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO GO
AFTER THE TARGET, THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS A GUY WHO LEADS AT ALL.
WORSE THAN ALL THAT, WORSE THAN
ALL THAT AND I WANT TO REPEAT
WHAT I SAID IN THE OPENING.
WHY WASN'T THAT GIVEN TO
CONGRESS?
WHY DID I FIND OUT ABOUT THAT
TODAY AT NOON?
THIS IS A CLASSIC CASE OF
OBSTRUCTION BUT THE QUESTION IS
WHO'S GOING TO INVESTIGATE THESE
GUYS?
WE'RE GOING TO BE VERY
TRANSPARENT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WERE GOING TO GET ALL
THE DOCUMENTS WE WANT.
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ALL GOING TO
SPILL OUT AND PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO ASK, WELL, WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO?
WHO IS GOING TO GET BUSTED?
WHO'S GOING TO GO TO JAIL?
>> Laura: LISA PAGE'S TEXT WAS
RELEASED BEFORE BUT THE STRZOK
"DON'T WORRY.
NO, NO, NO WE'LL STOP IT."
THAT CAME TODAY.
>> HOP WITHOUT A POSSIBLY BEEN
REDACTED?
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THEY KEEP BLACKING THINGS OUT
ACROSS THE BOARD, NOT GIVING US
DOCUMENTS THAT AT THE END OF THE
DAY ALWAYS END UP BEING VERY
PERTINENT TO OUR INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: THE IG WROTE THE
FOLLOWING IN ONE PART OF THE
"UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES, WE
DO NOT HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
STRZOK'S DECISION TO PRIORITIZE
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION OF THE
FOLLOWING UP ON THE MIDYEAR
RELATED INVESTIGATION LEAD
INVESTIGATED DISCOVERED ON THE
WEINER LAPTOP WAS FREE FROM
BIAS."
SO THE IG CANNOT CONSTANTLY
STATE THAT IT WAS FREE FROM BIAS
STATE THAT IT WAS FREE FROM BIA
BIAS.
THEY ARE SAYING THERE WAS NO
POLITICAL BIAS ON THE PART OF
COMEY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DOWNPLAY IT.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT WE KNOW.
I'VE NEVER SAID THIS BEFORE.
WE HAD WHISTLE-BLOWERS BUT WE
COULDN'T REALLY USE THE
INFORMATION BUT NOW THAT IT'S IN
THE IG REPORT, WE CAN.
WE HAD WHISTLE-BLOWERS WHO CAME
TO US IN LATE SEPTEMBER OF 2016
WILL TALK TO US ABOUT THIS
LAPTOP SITTING IN NEW YORK THAT
HAD ADDITIONAL EMAILS ON IT.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTE
COMMITTEE, WE HAD IT BUT WE
COULDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> Laura: WHEN WAS THAT AGAIN?
>> INCORPORATED 2016.
>> Laura: DO YOU KNOW WHEN
EXACTLY?
>> ETIQUETTE WAS LATE SEPTEMBER.
>> Laura: ULTIMATELY THEY
DIDN'T MOVE ON THIS UNTIL LATE
OCTOBER.
>> GOOD FBI AGENTS BROUGHT THIS
TO OUR ATTENTION, BUT WHAT COULD
WE DO WITH IT?
>> Laura: THERE IS ANOTHER
EXCHANGE I WANT TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION.
>> I SAY THAT BECAUSE OF THE
CLASSIFIED AND THIS IS A GAME
THAT COMEY AND COMPANY HAVE BEEN
PLAYING THAT THEY HIDE BEHIND
THIS --
>> Laura: THEY ALL THOUGHT
HILLARY WAS GOING TO WIN.
ROCKING THE BOAT WAS TOUGH.
HE MADE A DECISION TO GO AFTER
THAT LAPTOP BECAUSE HE THOUGHT
IF SOMEONE FINDS OUT ABOUT IT,
THEY ARE GOING TO BAKE THE WHOLE
ELECTION WAS ILLEGITIMATE.
>> WHAT'S ALSO TRUE AS I THINK
THE SAME PEOPLE IN CHARGE TODAY
STILL BELIEVE THEY CAN RUN THE
CLOCK OUT AND THEY ARE TRYING TO
RUN THE CLOCK OUT FOR THE REST
OF THE CONGRESS THAT WE GET
FINISH OUR INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: ARE THERE STILL
PEOPLE IN THE FBI TODAY WHO
BELIEVE THEY OPERATE BY A
DIFFERENT SET OF RULES?
>> AT THE TOP.
AT THE TOP, I THINK THAT IS
STILL TRUE.
WE HEARD SOME GREAT WORD
STATEMENT CHRISTOPHER WRAY, THE
NEW DIRECTOR.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU IT'S A
LITTLE FRUSTRATING BECAUSE WE
HAVE THESE VERY CONVERSATIONS
WITH HIM MANY MONTHS AGO WHERE
WE SAID LOOK, YOU ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY OF IT.
YOU NEED TO CLEAN THIS UP, AND
WE WILL SUPPORT YOU AND CLEANING
IT UP BUT YET HERE IT IS TODAY
WE GET THIS TEXT MESSAGE AT NOON
TODAY, ONE THAT'S ABSENTLY
PERTINENT TO OUR INVESTIGATION.
MAYBE THEY HAVE A GOOD EXCUSE
FOR IT BUT THE PROBLEM WITH IT
IS IF THEY DIDN'T GIVE IT TO US
IT'S A PROBLEM.
IF THEY DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT
IT'S AN EVEN BIGGER PROBLEM.
>> Laura: THERE'S OTHER
THINGS, ANOTHER EXCHANGE.
FBI ATTORNEY SENT --
THEY DON'T IDENTIFY WHO THIS IS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
WHO THIS IS.
FOR SOME REASON, WE CAN'T GET
THE PERSON'S NAME.
FBI ATTORNEY NUMBER TO SEND AN
INSTANT MESSAGE TO FBI ATTORNEY
NUMBER ONE COMMENTING ON THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THE SUBJECT
OF AN FBI INVESTIGATION HAVE
BEEN PAID WHILE WORKING ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
FBI ATTORNEY ONE SAYS IS IT
MAKING YOU RETHINK YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION?
FBI ATTORNEY NUMBER TWO SAYS
HELL NO.
>> THE IG REPORT, THERE'S FIVE
PEOPLE BEEN KICKED OFF THE
CAMPAIGN.
IF THERE'S FIVE PEOPLE BEEN
KICKED OFF THE CAMPAIGN OR OFF
THE MUELLER TEAM, HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE IF YOU LOOK AT THE REST
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE, THEY
WERE ALL CLINTON DONORS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS IS GOING
TO END UP FAIRLY.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Laura: SHOULD WE LEARN THE
NAMES OF THESE ATTORNEYS WHO
WERE SENDING THESE MESSAGES WHO
WERE PART OF THE RESISTANCE?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY.
UNLESS THEY ARE AND ARE
UNDERCOVER AGENT.
>> Laura: IT SAYS THEY ARE
ATTORNEYS.
>> THIS IS THE TYPE OF STUFF
THAT ALWAYS HAPPENS.
>> Laura: NOW I KNOW YOU HOW
YOU FEEL BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
IT'S HAPPENING TO THE WHOLE
COUNTRY NOW.
THERE WAS ANOTHER ISSUE
INVOLVING FBI EMPLOYEES AT EVERY
LEVEL OF THE ORGANIZATION.
THIS IS FROM THE REPORT.
WITH NO OFFICIAL REASON TO BE IN
CONTACT WITH THE MEDIA.
WHO WERE NEVERTHELESS IN
FREQUENT CONTACT WITH REPORTERS.
THE LARGE NUMBER OF FBI
EMPLOYEES WHO WERE IN CONTACT
WITH JOURNALISTS DURING THIS
TIME.
IMPACTED OUR ABILITY TO IDENTIFY
LEAKS.
AND THEY WERE GETTING PERKS,
GETTING TICKETS.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN LEAKING LIKE
CRAZY.
THE PROBLEM IS THE IG REPORT
DISCOVERED THAT.
THIS HAPPENED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO.
BUT DON'T FORGET THE LEAK THAT
JUST OCCURRED LAST WEEK WHERE AT
MIDNIGHT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SENDS OUT THIS DEVIN
NUNES AND PAUL RYAN HAD A CHANCE
TO READ DOCUMENTS AND THEY
DIDN'T READ THEM.
REMEMBER THAT?
THAT WAS A LEAK IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT, IT MIDNIGHT PRESS
RELEASE SO THAT WE WOULD WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING AND HAVE TO
ANSWER ALL THIS NEW NARRATIVE
THEY ARE CREATING THE
REPUBLICANS ASKED FOR DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH.
IT'S NOT AS IF THE LEAKS HAVE
STOPPED.
NOW THEY ARE DOING IT, THE FBI
PEOPLE WERE LEAKING.
NOW IT'S AT THE TOP LEVEL THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT'S
LEAKING.
>> Laura: THERE WAS A FEW
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA DOWNPLAYING
ALL OF THIS GRANT WANT TO PLAY
FOR YOU A SHORT MONTAGE.
WATCH.
>> I EXPECTED A SLEDGEHAMMER.
WE GOT THE SAME KIND OF HAMMER
USED TO NAIL PAINTING ON THE
WALL.
I WAS SURPRISED AT HOW MILD IT
WAS.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE ASSAULT ON
THE FBI THAT'S TAKEN PLACE,
THAT'S BEEN THE CALL OF SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION SAYING THESE ARE
CROOKS.
THEY ARE CORRUPT.
THEY TRIED TO THROW AN ELECTION.
THIS REPORT DOES NOT SAY THAT.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMEN.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE ONE
GENTLEMAN ON THERE, THAT'S THE
GUY THAT IT IS ONE OF COMEY'S
BUDDIES WORKING AT THE FBI.
A LOT OF THESE AGENTS, THE OTHER
NETWORKS HAVE HIRED ALL OF THESE
FORMER FBI AND DOJ CLINTON
PEOPLE AND OBAMA PEOPLE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
>> Laura: NOTHING THERE TO
SEE.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU STILL HAVE A
LOT MORE TO GET TO WITH THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
>> WE ARE ALMOST THERE.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE.
THERE'S A REASON WHY THEY'VE
BEEN HIDING THESE DOCUMENTS FOR
TWO MONTHS.